what should we start with with peptides
dude because this is something that is
incredibly important and we've talked
before about how the medical system
doesn't really
it's not really designed to operate in
such a way where it provides health care
it more or less provides sick care where
it keeps you
on their drugs and their prescriptions
uh as long as possible in an unhealthy
and inflamed body
um what
what was it that brought you to peptides
why don't we start with that like what
are peptides and what brought you to
peptides yeah so for so for for just for
the purposes of like letting people know
how profound they are and you know this
when we met in person
i wasn't as bald as richard but i was
pretty close i mean this is my hair is
the result of peptides okay i've regrown
my hair
uh at the age of nearly 52 um you know
through the peptide that you know we can
talk about at some point in the show
that you know is a company that i own uh
ghk it's called oxnano grow but it's gh
kcu copper peptide and carbon 60
together
but that's to let people know i don't
have a before and after but you can go
on my website you know richard showed
him before
uh and i know richard you've used it
before and you even grew and like the
areas that you had your hair started
coming back in but i mean i know your
chrome dome that's your look whatever
but yeah the reality is is that peptides
are essentially fractionated proteins
uh organic in nature that are now
synthesized in a lab that could do all
sorts of
you know wonderful modalities from
healing to help with cognition to
enhancing immunity to extending telomere
length you know enhancing longevity
uh profound cognitive and healing stuff
fat loss muscle gain i mean there's so
many different things about peptides
that we haven't even really gotten into
um and as as you said they are the the
future
of medicine and i hate using the word
medicine because like you said it's dead
right like people think of medicine like
sick care give me a band-aid or a pill
and peptides are treating the root cause
of whatever your issue is and then
fundamentally
offering a regenerative effect
yeah that's that's that's a fair way to
put it um
how are they changing over time because
i think you've mentioned you first
started using them uh 15 20 years ago
like in the 2000s basically yeah are
they are they getting better they
improving is anything changing or is it
pretty much the same you know technology
today so it's a great question so they
are improving uh we're actually moving
from peptides to
um you know essentially uh bioregulators
which that that's a whole other show you
and i can do that really the patents are
owned by by russian scientists and
they're
truly uh more profound than peptides are
now i don't want to like get people to
like say oh [ __ ] how do i get them
because you really can't get them there
are companies that sell them
offshore pharmacies but i don't really
quote unquote trust them because i
personally haven't used them myself and
stuff like that but i've read the
research
but to really drill down on your
question
i started using peptides in 2005 2006. i
can't really remember i know i started
with using a company called
i'm sorry ipa moreland was the peptide
the company was called southern research
company
and they were literally just the back
office of a compounding pharmacy you
know back in the day in texas and
to again answer your question more
directly as we've evolved and peptides
have become more ubiquitous you know in
medical circles and doctors functional
medicine doctors holistic healer
practitioners uh i believe that it's uh
like everything else with wonder pills
drugs supplements you know people start
diluting things because they see the
money opportunities so you do have to be
what i would call buyer beware where you
get your peptides now
just so everybody knows uh you know
every country has different laws and
classifications around
the usage of peptides
thankfully there are peptides that are
quote unquote fda approved and obviously
if the fda rubber stamps it it's pretty
much good anywhere else
around the world because of the way that
system works again that's a whole other
subject but
they are under scrutiny richard they
have always been under scrutiny because
obviously they represent a massive
threat
to the profit system of big pharma and
sick care right like if if if
i'll give you a perfect example and you
know this personally if you tear your
knee at 45 and up and you have an acl
and an mcl reconstruction
a legitimate orthopedic surgeon who's
familiar with using peptides you know
has a moral
and a financial dilemma to their
practice because they could give you
bpc157 and tb 500 and heal you better or
i'm sorry as good or better than any
reconstructive surgery but as you know
the reconstructive surgeries cost 60 000
or whatever they are through benefits
and then he gets his 18 to 22 grand you
know your insurance you pay make a
co-payment if you have insurance and
you're lucky enough of 3 500 or whatever
it is and the game's that way but we now
know and again i've interviewed people
on my podcast some of the world's top
orthopedist who will say
if you're 45 or 50 and i know about the
structural you know loss at you know due
to age i'm not going to do that surgery
on you i'm going to give you you know
bpc157 tb 500 for two months and call it
a day and you're gonna get just as great
regenerative effect and regrowth of the
tendons and the ligaments and you know
the structural integrity of the actual
injured joint better than you would for
me cutting on you so it's it's crazy how
much they've replaced you know this idea
that oh you know i tore my shoulder oh i
tore my acl and i have to have surgery
yeah um i've i've personally used bpc157
um for joint issues and tb 500 tb is
more for like muscle tissue right yeah
tb 500 is for instant um
inflammation suppression so if you have
a massive injury like you blow your acl
you blow your shoulder out you want to
use that
you know in the first 10 to 14 days but
then yeah as you know the bpc157 which
stands for body protective compound is
literally like a magic potion when you
use it yeah and i've used that on my
knee and it and it it is it like i like
i healed my knee i've you know i've had
issues with like standing uh over long
periods like standing in lineups like
when we met up we were in la uh visiting
we did of course you know the universal
and the disney because i was there with
my kid we were doing a little bit of a
trip and like standing in line ups and
like you know like all that bull crap oh
horrible it you know when you get older
you know your joints start to wear out
it's like you know you're kind of [ __ ]
because you get older and
something like this is actually very
very helpful and i was hesitant to use
it for a while like i just i just did
the standard you know like take this
stuff from from costco or the
glucosamine and chondroitin and you know
the standard like you know healing
things there was even a article that i
read one time that said just eat just
eat loads of jello because it's got
gelatin and that'll get in your joints
and that'll lubricate them and it'll be
all better but none of that stuff worked
and i got over my uh i don't know anita
litus or whatever the problem was you
know that i had but it's a 30 gauge very
short fine needle you inject it very
close to your joint there's a little bit
of lump there from the from the liquid
because it's a water-based fluid and you
know you know you kind of massage it in
and literally within a few weeks like
two to three weeks there's a pretty
significant improvement and i think
within about a month maybe five or six
weeks
no troubles at all and
it's healed it's healed like i don't
have problems again um anytime i've
injured like any joint in my body i've
i've got two bottles of bpc-157 in my
fridge it's not um compounded like it's
not mixed yet
um but i just keep there in case i hurt
myself and i've done things i'm going to
tell you that you know you do something
stupid like you mess up your back like
i'm a tall guy like you and i mess up my
back sometimes i just just lie on my
stomach i pop in a syringe my girlfriend
just grabs a clump of skin you know
where it hurts injects it in there
you're good
it's totally true i literally was just
going to tell you that i've made the
mistake of leaving home without it you
know when i travel i travel so much and
it's like i will never make that mistake
again i mean i literally take
a vial of tb 500 and bbc combined and by
the way before people ask yes you can
combine them there are compound
pharmacies that will push them together
i recommend keeping them separate for
what the reasons richard already said
because you want the tb for when you're
seriously injured and then you want the
bpc as a maintenance dose which is what
you're talking about but yeah absolutely
you can inject bpc for any injury i mean
really any soft tissue ligament tendon
your swell you know you're strained i
did it with my bicep too by the way
joints dude bicep detachment like i must
have had a mild tear or something i just
did a couple of shots like right here in
like the
meat of it all yeah about a week or two
like three or four shots fine bro i've
seen guys tear the entire distal part of
the bicep like where the intent you know
the insertion is right here yeah that's
that's the epc
i mean tore it off the bone and you know
where it's like a purple bruise yeah
yeah and i've seen guys inject bpc and
you know before and afters of one month
and it completely heals it now you're
still going to have that scar from where
it detached but it does it completely
heals it and no there's no modality in
any surgical ward
that can do that as you know it's not
possible hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you